let us take this
short stroll through the park of the
meaning of life
daniel uh what is a meaningful life
i think um the semantics end up
mattering because a lot of people
will take the word meaning and the word
purpose
almost interchangeably and they'll talk
they'll think kind of what is the
meaning of my life what is the meaning
of human life what is the meaning of
life what's the meaning of the universe
and what what is the meaning of
existence rather non-existent so there's
a lot of kind of existential
considerations there and i think there's
some cognitive mistakes that are very
easy like
taking the idea of purpose which is like
a goal
which is a utilitarian concept the
purpose of one thing is defined in
relationship to other things that have
assumed value
um and to say what is the purpose of
everything well
it's a purpose is too small of a
question it's fundamentally a relative
question within everything what is the
purpose of one thing relative to another
what is the purpose of everything and
there's nothing outside of it with which
to say it
you actually just got to the limits of
the utility of the
concept of purpose it doesn't mean it's
purposeless in the sense of something
inside of it being purposeless it means
the concept is too small
which is why you end up getting to you
know like in taoism talking about
the nature of it rather the there's a
fundamental what
where the why can't go deeper it is the
nature of it um
but uh i'm gonna try to speak to a much
simpler
part which is when people think about
what is a meaningful human life
and kind of if we were to optimize for
something at the level of individual
life
but also how does optimizing for this at
the level of the individual life
lead to the best
society for insofar as people living
that way affects others
and long-term the world as a whole and
how would we then
make a civilization that was trying to
think about these things
because you can see that there are a lot
of dialectics where
there's value on two sides individualism
and collectivism or
the ability to accept things and the
ability to push harder and whatever
and there's failure modes on both sides
and so when you were starting to say
okay individual happiness you're like
wait sadists can be happy while
hurting people it's not individual
happiness it's love but wait some people
can
self-sacrifice out of love in a way that
actually ends up just creating
codependency for everybody
um or okay so so how do we think about
all those things together
one like this kind of came to me as a
a simple way that i kind of relate to it
is
that a meaningful life involves the mode
of being
the mode of doing and the mode of
becoming and it involves a virtuous
relationship between those three and
that any of those modes on their own
also have failure modes that are not a
meaningful life
the mode of being the way i would
describe it
if if we're talking about um the essence
of it
is about taking in and appreciating the
beauty of life that is now
it's a mode that is in the moment and
that is
largely about being with what is
it's fundamentally grounded in the
nature of experience and the
meaningfulness of experience
the prima facie meaningfulness of when
i'm having this experience
i'm not actually asking what the meaning
of life is i'm actually full of it i'm
full of experiencing it
the momentary experience yes
so taking in the beauty of life
doing is adding to the beauty of life
i'm going to produce some art
i'm going to produce some technology
that will make life easier more
beautiful for somebody else
i'm going to uh do some science that
will end up leading to better
insights or others people's ability to
appreciate the beauty of life more
because they understand more about it or
whatever it is
or protect it right i'm going to protect
it in some way but that's adding to
or being in service of the beauty of
life through our doing and becoming
is getting better at both of those being
able to deepen our being
which is to be able to take in the
beauty of life more profoundly
be more moved by it touched by it
and increasing our capacity with doing
to add to the beauty of life
more and
so i hold that a meaningful life has to
be all three of those
and where they're not in conflict with
each other
ultimately it grounds in being it
grounds in the intrinsic meaningfulness
of experience
and then my doing is ultimately
something that will
be able to increase the possibility of
the quality of experience for others
and my becoming is a deepening on those
so it grounds an experience and also the
evolutionary possibility of experience
and the point is to
[Music]
oscillate between these never getting
stuck on anyone
yeah or i suppose in parallel well you
can't really attention is a thing
you can only allocate attention
i want moments where i am absorbed in
the sunset and
i'm not thinking about what to do next
and then
the fullness of that can make it to
where my doing doesn't come from what's
in it for me
because i actually feel overwhelmingly
full already
and then it's like how can i how can i
make life better for other people that
don't have as much opportunities i had
how can i add something wonderful how
can i just be in the creative process
and
so i think where the doing comes from
matters and if the doing comes from a
fullness of being
it's inherently going to be paying
attention to externalities
or it's more oriented to do that than if
it comes from some emptiness that
is trying to get full in some way that
is willing to cause sacrifices other
places and where a chunk of its
attention is internally focused
and so when buddha said desire is the
cause of all suffering then
later the vow of the bodhisattva which
was to show up for all sentient beings
in universe forever
is a pretty intense thing like desire
i would say there is a kind of desire if
we think of desire as a basis for
movement like a flow or a gradient
there's a kind of desire
that comes from something missing inside
seeking fulfillment of that
in the world that ends up being the
cause of actions that perpetuate
suffering
but there's also not just non-desire
there's a kind of desire that comes from
feeling full at the beauty of life and
wanting to add to it
that is a flow this direction and
i don't think that is the cause of
suffering i think that is
you know and the western traditions
right the eastern traditions focused on
that
and kind of unconditional happiness
outside of them in the moment outside of
time western tradition said no actually
desire is the source of creativity and
we're here to be
made in the image and likeness of the
creator we're here to be fundamentally
creative
but creating from where and in service
of what
creating from a sense of connection to
everything and wholeness in service of
the well-being of all of it
is very different
which is back to that compassion
conversion axis being doing becoming
pretty powerful
also could potentially be algorithmized
into a robot
just saying
you